people use women's rights as a  justification for abortion  and i think that's the most sort of  persuasive argument for a lot of people  are like well i believe in women's  rights so yeah i guess i  support abortion i am 100 myself for  women's rights i think women's rights  are human  human rights i think as humans we have  rights but my rights  end where another person's rights begin  so  as a woman i never have the right to  kill an innocent child  even if that child is inconvenient to me  even if that child is sick even if that  child's struggling  i hope and pray that woman gets support  and we should focus on trying to support  her like he said that's hard that's  it's complicated but it's never my right  to kill to solve a problem  and so well that is i think the the  argument like i have this right to do it  i would  say let's have a different vision for  women's rights ones that are  non-violent and ultimately see and see  and respect the lives of all people